we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail
I got about how I deal with callers to
the David Pakman show
take a listen hey David I'm a big fan of
the show I just want to call in and ask
you not to be well I am I can ask this
what are your tips for dealing with rude
callers to call you probably on a daily
basis because I work I worked I just
quit my job I worked in the service
industry and well okay how do you deal
through people call into your show yeah
I don't know if I'm the right person to
ask because a lot of people criticize me
for not dealing with callers well I mean
that's a common criticism that I'm
either not giving someone enough time to
lay out their question even if they want
five minutes to lay out a question when
I've got thirty people holding or that I
am being condescending sometimes to call
or so I I don't know that I'm the right
person I try to do the best I can and
sort of balance the level of hostility
of the caller with whether they're
actually providing a question or a
comment a value with how I assume or
infer that the rest of the audience is
dealing with this caller and I just try
to do the best I can but no matter what
I get criticized if I rush callers off
too quickly when they're not making a
point people write in and say David
you're being rude to the callers if I
allow people to do soliloquies
uncontrolled for minutes on end I get
emails saying David you know you really
got to learn how to take control of
these callers you can't allow them to
just go on and monopolize the show like
that so what I've come to realize is
that my handling of callers is sort of a
no-win scenario and I just need to do
the best I can and certainly listen if
you work in customer service at a call
center the last thing you should be
doing for the sake of your job is to be
taking guidance from me during live
calls as to how to handle customer
service calls very very different
situation the live callers can't fire me
although I guess the audience could in
the sense that
if they really don't like how I handle
calls they could cancel memberships but
the last thing I would ever recommend
someone do is to look at my live calls
to figure out how to do customer service
as a job definitely don't do that we've
got a great bonus show for you today
very sad news from the world of index
funds vanguards founder John Bogle has
passed away and this is someone whose
work I have followed for a very long
time and who has an investment
philosophy along with the late great Ben
Graham that is basically my investment
philosophy and we'll talk about that on
today's bonus show we will also talk
about a hotel dishwasher who has been
awarded 21 million dollars after her
boss made her work on Sundays and lastly
on today's bonus show Netflix is
increasing subscription prices it's
churning churning out a lot of original
content some of which I am not finding
to be that good and also pulling non
original content that I really like so
we will talk about what's going on with
Netflix and much more on today's bonus
show two ways to get access to the bonus
show number one become a member at WWJ
impact mancom number 2 become a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show